we start with the big drama Stateside
from Netflix's top dating show love is
blind yeah the real show seems to be the
one you don't see behind the scenes the
show's alumni claiming there was nothing
to love about their time on reality TV
what is the official diagnosis that
you've gotten I have depression anxiety
PTSD
flaws kind of bubble up to the surface
20-hour work days sleep deprivation
psychological warfare and a lack of food
and water which quote literally ruins
lives those are the allegations
contained in a blistering Business
Insider expose season two contestant
Danielle rule told me she entered the
dating show with a history of mental
health struggles she alleges show
producers did little to provide support
did you identify that you were dealing
with some mental health issues I hadn't
been suicidal since high school and I
had disclosed those things
um during the psycho valve and when they
said okay you're fine now I believe that
to be the truth but I probably shouldn't
have partied I hate bread
to make me feel better Danielle claims
it all came to a head while vacationing
in Mexico with Future Husband Nick
Thompson my anxiety was boiling up at
this point I did go into the closet to
have a panic attack because I was really
scared that their rooms were bugged I
sat in the closet
I locked the door I shut this and I sat
in the closet and cried two of The
Producers I said you know what I'm not
trusting myself right now I've tried
putting suicide in the past in that
moment they all came rushing in and
instead of sending a therapist they all
kind of persuaded us to stay in an
environment that I knew wasn't going to
be healthy for me so at no time did they
offer you therapy therapist help no this
all comes on the heels of Sunday night's
live finale debacle which triggered a
petition to fire host Nick and Vanessa
Lachey and concerns for contestant Shane
Jansen after this bizarre Instagram live
when you have 14 000 people watching you
singlely yeah you tell yourself to relax
as well kinetic content which produces
Love is Blind tells E.T quote we have
rigorous protocols in place to care for
each person before during and after
filming there was absolutely no
therapist on set there was absolutely no
support after filming and I will take
that to my grave why not leave the shop
there were consequences in leaving the
show they do film you 24 7. here's the
concern that there will be video that
could refute some of these allegations
oh no there's a lot of things that I
could have said that I haven't this is
my 100 truth
[Music]